we have three lines and we have to
figure out which of the three are
parallel so line a and it can't be
parallel on its own has to be parallel
to another of the three lines so the
equation for line a is y is equal to 3/4
X minus for line B line B is 4 y 4 y
minus 20 is equal to negative 3 X and
then line C line C is negative 3x plus 4
y is equal to 40 so to figure out if any
of these lines are parallel to any of
the other lines we just have to compare
their slopes if any of these two lines
if any two of these lines have the same
slope and there are different lines they
have different y-intercepts then they're
going to be parallel
now line a it's very easy to figure out
its slope it's already in slope
intercept form this is M X plus B the
slope is 3/4 and the y-intercept which
isn't as relevant when you're figuring
out parallel lines is negative 4 so
let's see what the other character
slopes are this isn't in any kind of
standard form it's not in standard form
slope intercept or point-slope form but
let's see what the slope of this line is
so to get it into slope intercept form
which is really the easiest one to
figure pick out the slope from let's add
20 to both sides of this equation so
let's add 20 to both sides the left-hand
side those cancel out that was the whole
point you get for Y is equal to negative
3x plus 20 and now we can divide
everything by 4 divide everything by 4
just dividing both sides of this
equation by 4 we are left with Y is
equal to negative 3/4 X plus 5 so in
this case y-intercept is 5 but most
importantly the slope is negative 3/4 so
it's different than this guy this is
negative 3/4 this is positive 3/4 so
these two guys definitely aren't
parallel let's move on to this guy this
guy written in standard form let's get
the X term on the other side so let's
add 3x to both sides of this equation
let's add 3x to both sides of this
equation
left-hand side these cancel out we're
just left with 4y is equal to 3x plus 40
or 40 plus 3x either way now we can
divide both sides by 4 we have to divide
every term by for the left-hand side
you're left with Y the right-hand side
you have three fourths X plus 10 so here
our slope is 3/4 and our y-intercept if
we won't care about it is 10 so this
line and this line have the exact same
slope 3/4 and there are different lines
because their y-intercept is different
so we know that a and C are parallel
lines and B is not parallel to neither
one of the other two